les rambolitains entendait encore
aujourd'hui le bruit des roues d'un
carrosse autour du château dans les
années 1770 riche propriétaire de saint
léger en yvelines décide d'emmener sa
compagne au château de rambouillet pour
une balade en carrosse dans le parc à
mi-chemin dans un endroit reculé du parc
le carrosse s'arrête et donc le
propriétaire décide d'aller voir ce qui
se passe et là il découvre son cocher
décapité qui tient encore les rênes donc
de peur il emmène sa belle et s'enfuit
l'histoire vieille de trois siècles se
transmet entre les employés du château
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je travaille
qui nous en a parlé donc ça remonte à
quelques années quand même puisque
parfois il essayé de savoir en allant se
balader dans le parc quand il y avait
pas beaucoup de monde et c'est
d'entendre ce bruit mais je pense qu'il
faut attendre la nuit tombée quand même
un point pour l'entendre le fantôme du
cocher hante le domaine royal mais pas
seulement louis xiv charles 10 ou
plusieurs présidents de la troisième
république y ont séjourné et leur esprit
rôderait dans les lieux avec tous les
personnages qui sont passés dans ce
château on peut peut-être enfin moi j'y
crois a d'autres qui sont cartésien n'y
croiront pas du tout mais moi je me dis
que pourquoi pas justement avoir des
âmes des personnes qui sont passés par
ici qu'ils restent dans les murs une
histoire peu connue des visiteurs mais
le message envoyé par le château est
clair les curieux sont les bienvenus à
rambouillet la présence des fantômes
n'est pas tabou